so a lot of Nintendo first party games
you know take advantage of the wii u
gamepad but we don't see that a lot from
third parties but i think one way that
Nintendo's trying to shore up that
difference it is going to end use and
having them like use the their their
devices in creative ways and one way
that they we saw that today was
affordable space adventures portable
space adventure not the best title but
but I think it gets it across it's a
space adventure it's an affordable game
you don't happen to like buy a rocket
ship and go to outer space I thought it
was really cool now you were playing you
were actually playing on the gamepad me
and Rob were on controllers what were
you doing on the gamepad I think I was
the engineer so I was literally
controlling the spaceship I think it's
called a portable spaceship because we
got like a really junky one we do not
agree it was very drunk and so I
literally would turn on all of the the
ship systems I could control a thrust
that could control the antigravity
sensors and then you were controlling
the ship's movement so we had to
coordinate back and forth I'm not
watching the screen as much as I'm
looking at my gamepad and watching you
guys play and I'm watching my sensors to
make sure that we're not gonna run out
of fuel we're not going to overheat our
thrusters or if we need to switch
between electrical power or like regular
fuel but you were playing the actual
game my focus was completely on making
sure we don't explode and then
occasionally accidentally shutting off
the ship and then dropping me to my dad
yes I know oh I really liked it I really
liked that I had to move the ship and
you had to do everything else and then
we had another player who was using our
flashlights to shining on enemies and to
illuminate what was ahead and I really
liked that we had to talk like we were
playing a game together but we were also
talking in the meat space and it was
kind of nice it's cooperative I mean
it's fun to play these competitive couch
games where you're you know you're
trying to knock the other person off and
trying to get some kind of advantage you
don't have a lot of cooperative games
that you play on the couch together and
and this really exemplified a great way
to do that
well fox boy ! is an adorable cute
protagonists you're literally a box and
you create other boxes to get you where
you need to go and it's sort of like
Mario and that you have like the pits if
you fall in the pit you guy if you fall
in the spikes you die and you have to
climb over obstacles which are just
little blocks to collect crowns and
every level has a certain number of
crowns and you get them and you can get
perfect scores and like that's how you
complete the level grint if you don't
have to collect them all but it has
beneficial if you do and sometimes
there's a limit you can only create one
box and you have to use it to surmount
obstacles or you can create three boxes
and you can either do straight lines or
do like a little step like a step
formation to get you where you need to
go or cover traps and reach these crowns
and whenever you generate a new set of
boxes your last set of previously
generated boxes disappears so you can't
you can't have a lot of boxes on the
playing field like you only have a
certain number out at once and I was
really mellowed out like I felt really
mellow I felt really relaxed and I'm a
sucker for like the tiny puzzles like
captain toad like you have the small
contained puzzle with a bunch of
different ways to solve it and I that's
what I like about box way I think it's
great so we have smash brothers as the
definitive Wii U Nintendo party game but
something we saw today was run Bo
it's taking that race in and the being
able to play against your friends and
sabotage one another but kind of
condensing it down into a really a crazy
bright beautiful way to really real
friends a little bit played out like
when you're watching it it's fun to
watch but you don't quite understand
what's going on for a couple minutes
because you see like whole color swaths
of color taking over the over the the
screen and what that's doing is there
are platforms that you see when that
color comes across the screen any
platform of the pets color disappear if
you can't stand on it so if you're stuck
on that platform you fall to your death
below or platforms can suddenly appear
that weren't there before and that will
aid you in getting to the goal whoever
gets the loot in the mode that we were
watching clever it gets to the goal
first you know it's a poison it was like
one out of 15 and there are also those
powers that you collect along the way
that let you either you know to like a
super strong punch or swap places with a
letter player and like using that it's
just the right moment can just like
create such an infuriating sense of like
oh you I'm so so [ __ ] win
you